MOUSE-BACK RIDING.
DANA PERINO AND "THE FIVE."
>>> AS TRUMP VISITS THE U.K.,
ANOTHER NASTY DISPLAY BY THE
MEDIA.
THEY TOLD THE PRESIDENT ABOUT A
ANTI-TRUMP RANT BY DUTCHESS,
MEGAN.
TRUMP CLEARLY REFERRING TO THE
COMMENTS SAID HE DIDN'T KNOW SHE
WAS NASTY TO HIM.
THE PRESS PORTRAYING IT AS TRUMP
CALLING HER NASTY.
IT'S NOT THE SAME THING.
THE MEDIA ERUPTS AFTER TRUMP
CALLS THE LONDON MAYOR A LOSER.
THAT WAS AFTER THE MAYOR CALLED
HIM A BIGOT.
THE TRUMP SAID THE MAYOR WAS AS
DUMB AS de BLASIO BUT HALF AS
TALL.
THAT'S FUNNY.
THIS WHOLE THING IS FUNNY.
WHEN HYSTERIA MEETS THE
HYSTERICAL.
BECAUSE TIMES ARE GOOD WHEN
FRONT PAGE NEWS ISN'T WAR BUT A
SILLY FEUD.
ME, I WOULD RATHER HAVE A
VOLATILE PRESIDENT PRESIDING
OVER GOOD TIMES THAN A BORING
PRESIDENT PRESIDING OVER BAD.
>>> MEANWHILE, SKY NEWS TOUTS A
BALLOON.
WHEN YOUR ANALYSIS IS REDUCED TO
A BLOW-UP TOY, MAYBE LONDON'S
ADULTS HAVE FINALLY LEFT THE
BUILDING.
EUROPEAN CLONES ALWAYS WRONG
WITH THE BIG THINGS.
THE MEDIA'S THREE FAVORITE
WORDS, WE KNOW BEST.
THE THREE WORDS THEY WILL NEVER
SAY THAT COULD SAVE THEM, WE
WERE WRONG.
THEY PROTEST TRUMP AS A POPULISM
SWEEPS THEIR COUNTRY.
IT IS SOMETHING EVERYONE SEES
BUT THEM, THE RISE OF THE BREXIT
PARTY MADE POSSIBLE BY THE
MEDIA'S BLANKET SNEER OF THE
AVERAGE BRIT HAS NOW MADE THAT
THEIR TRUMP.
THE ISLAND FEELS SMALLER, A
PLACE WHERE NOT JUST TRUMP ISN'T
WELCOME BUT ALSO JOHN CLEAT,
MORISSY AND WHEN TRUMP IS GONE
AND THEY BATHE IN NOSTALGIA NOR
THEIR OWN DAYS OF HATE, ALL THEY
WILL HAVE IS THEIR STUPID
BALLOON.
>> DANNY, YOU HAVE BEEN TO THESE
THINGS, CAN WE SHOW SOME OF
THESE V.O.?
>> VOICEOVER.
>> THIS IS THE BANQUET THAT'S
GOING ON.
I'M JUST GOING TO SAY THAT I
DON'T THINK THERE IS ANYTHING
THAT COULD BE MORE MISSERABLE
THAN THIS.
EVERYBODY IS SERIOUS.
NO ONE IS SMILING.
IS THIS JUST MISERABLE FOR
EVERYBODY.
>> I SEE WHAT YOU MEAN.
BECAUSE IT IS ALL PRIM AND
PROPER, YOU CAN'T JUST HANG OUT,
YOU HAVE TO MIND YOUR Ps AND Qs.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER, COURTESY,
DON'T COURTESY, SHAKE A HAND,
DON'T SHAKE A HAND, ALL THOSE
THINGS YOU CANNOT DO.
THAT IS A BEAUTIFUL SETTING.
IT IS A REALLY GOOD SYMBOLISM
FOR AMERICA AND THE U.K. COMING
TOGETHER.
LOOK AT THAT.
THAT'S GORGEOUS.
>> IT IS.
PHYSICAL GOING TO BE TABLE.
>> YOU KNOW BRITISH FOOD.
THAT'S HYSTERICAL.
WHAT IS IT, FISH?
>> IT WILL BE FISH.
>> FISH AND LAMB.
THE TWO ANIMALS THAT SMELL.
I HADN'T THOUGHT OF THAT.
IT SMELLS BADLY TOO, NOT GOOD.
>> IS HE HELPED BY BEING
INSULTED?
>> IT HELPS HIM, YOU ANY?
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> TWO-THIRDS OF BRITAIN
DISAPPROVED OF TRUMP.
HE THINKS POSSIBLY THAT IT PUMPS
UP HIS RATINGS.
I DON'T THINK THE MEDIA TOLD
TRUMP TO LIE.
HE IS THE ONE THAT SAID SHE
WAS -- HE DIDN'T KNOW SHE WAS
NASTY.
>> ABOUT HIM?
>> I DIDN'T KNOW SHE WAS NASTY.
>> WHAT HE SAID?
I DIDN'T KNOW SHE WAS NASTY.
HE WAS READ THE QUOTE WHERE SHE
WAS CRITICAL OF HIM.
>> I THINK WHAT WAS AMAZING TO
ME IS RETWEETS THE TAPE.
YOU CAN LISTEN FOR YOURSELF.
IT IS NOT ME AND GREG AND DANA
DISAGREEING.
HE ACTUALITILY SAID THAT, I
DIDN'T KNOW.
>> WHAT I'M SAYING IS, BECAUSE
HE KNOWS.
HE SAID, I DIDN'T KNOW SHE WAS
NASTY, LIKE SAYING THAT DANA
SAID SOMETHING NASTY TO ME.
>> THAT'S NOT NICE.
>> AS USUALLY, IN OUR POLARIZED
ERA, IT'S ALMOST ORWELLIAN.
HE IS SAYING, DON'T BELIEVE THE
FAKE NEWS AND THE FAKE MEDIA.
I DIDN'T KNOW "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" AND THE A.P. WAS SO
POWERFUL, WE COULD MAKE THE
PRESIDENT LIE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS
WHOLE MESS?
>> I WOULD LOVE TO GO TO ONE OF
THOSE SERVICES.
THAT'S MY DREAM.
THAT WOULD BE AMAZING.
>> WHY?
>> TO GET ALL DRESSED UP TO
REPRESENT THE STATES.
ALL THE HEADS OF STATE, IT WOULD
BE A FASCINATING COLLECTION OF
PEOPLE AND STATE REPRESENTATIVES
AND AN OPULENCE AND GLAMOUR.
THIS IS MY POINT ABOUT MAYOR
KHAN'S OP-ED.
WHY IT IS UNBRETTISH TO ROLL OUT
THE RED CARPET FOR TRUMP.
WHY DOESN'T HE MODEL THE
INCLUSION AND ALLEGED EMBRACING
OF EVERYONE HE PURPORTS TO
REPRESENT.
WHY AM I MEETING WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND THEN LIST IN HIS OP ED
THE SPECIFIC POLICY THINGS THAT
HE WANTS TO DISCUSS WITH HIM AND
CHANGE HIS MIND AND HOW THEY CAN
MEET IN THE MIDDLE, ET CETERA.
I THINK THIS WAS A FAILED
OPPORTUNITY ON HIS PART AND A
HYPER GENERAL.
>> IF I WAS THE PRESIDENT, WHY
WOULD I MEET WITH THE MAYOR?
>> I LOVE LONDON.
IT IS A BEAUTIFUL, BEAUTIFUL
CITY.
JESSE, I THINK YOU HAVEN'T MADE
IT UNTIL THEY MAKE A GIANT
BALLOON OF YOU.
>> ANY HAVE DESTROYED THE
SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
BRITAIN AND AMERICA.
THE QUEEN IS REALLY UNSETTLE.
SHE IS OBLIGATED TO DO IT.
THEY IGNORE THE GAFFE
THEY IGNORE THE  AFFE
THEY IGNORE THE  GAFE
THEY IGNORE THE  GAFFES.
HE FRIES TO TOASTTH THE QUEEN OF
ENGLAND.
THEY ARE PLAYING HER ANTHEM.
SHE IS NOT ALLOWED TO DO
ANYTHING BUT SIT THERE AND
WATCH.
THE MEDIA BURIED THAT AND GAVE
THE QUEEN A GIFT.
HE GAVE HER AN iPOD OF HIS
FAMOUS SPEECHES.
THAT WOULD BE LIKE DONALD TRUMP
SIGNING "ART OF THE DEAL" AND
GIVING IT TO THE QUEEN.
>> ISN'T BREXIT THE RESPONSE TO
THE MEDIA THE WAY TRUMP WAS?
>> THE POLITICIAN NS IN THE U.K.
COULDN'T PULL IT OFF.
>> IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ECONOMIC.
THEY WANTED TO CHANGE THE U.K.
>> HE HAS TO MEET WITH THERESA
MAY, WHO IS HAVING TROUBLE WITH
BREXIT.
WHAT DOES HE SAY?
THERESA MAY, YOU SHOULD HAVE
DONE BETTER.
YOU SHOULD HAVE DONE THIS.
MORE LIKE ME.
THAT'S OUR REPRESENTATIVE.
>> MY POINT IS, WHY WOULD YOU
MEET WITH THE MAYOR?
MEETING WITH THERESA MAY.
THERE IS THE HAT.
>> I AWAIT MY INVITATION.
>> ONE LAST QUESTION.
HOW DOES PETER FEEL ABOUT THE
JOHN CLEAT STUFF?
WE CAN TALK ABOUT IT DURING THE